Bitte schön.
Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Deso.
Ich bin der
Viertes mal.
richtig?
doppelten
genau
wie alt sind sie?
55 Jahre alt.
Wann sind sie genau geboren?
am 1. Mai 1969
okay
wissen Sie wie viel
Sie so sein wiegen?
Wie groß sind Sie? 1,70 m.
Danke für die Informationen.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was fürchtest du uns?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich wirklich ausgesprochen müde bin und gar nicht mehr belastbar bin.
Ich habe auch Gewicht verloren und das mache ich ein bisschen Sorgen.
Haben Sie Schmerzen oder gibt es Ende?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen mehr.
Haben Sie Schüttenfrost oder Schweißarsbruhe?
Auch nicht.
Gibt es Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Mosa?
Ich habe keine Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang, was etwas mehr lag.
Ich habe auch Pharmixinfekte in der letzten Zeit. Ich weiß nicht warum.
Können Sie bitte, ich konnte akustisch nicht gut hören.
Haben Sie Blut im Yrinbemakt?
Nein.
Ja, in der letzten Zeit läuft das. Ich weiß nicht, warum das so ist.
Seit wann haben Sie?
Ja, jetzt sind seit ungefähr 2-3 Monaten immer wieder.
Habt ihr die Blut im Urin bemerkt?
Nein.
Okay.
Habt ihr Kopfschmerzen oder war Ihnen einmal schwindelig?
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Wenn ich mich belaste, wird mir manchmal schwindelig, aber eigentlich nicht in Ruhe.
Okay.
Ein Moment, dass ich alles aufschreibe.
Habt ihr sonst noch irgendetwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Nein, die meinen Sie ungewöhnlich.
Abgesehen von dieser Müdigkeit, Gewichtsverlust,
dass ich mich auch immer wieder aufschreibe, was ich tun kann.
Genau, das ist das, was mir so ein bisschen Sorge macht.
Wenn ich sie nicht schwindelig habe, dann sehe ich auch nicht so gut.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum das so ist.
Ja, ist Ihnen Filmmann oder Schwarzforder in Augen aufgefallen?
Nee, durch die Schwarzforderung ist es mir nicht geworden.
Okay.
Habt ihr schon mal früher das same System gehabt?
Nein, nicht wirklich.
Alles klar.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob wichtige Erkrankheiten Sie haben.
Gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Also ich habe Bluthochtuck.
Seit wann?
Ja ungefähr seit 10 Jahren jetzt.
Und was haben Sie da für ein?
Ich will Lizzy Duprelein.
Lizzy Duprelein.
Lizzy Noopiril.
Wie viel Milligramm wissen Sie?
Einmal am Tag 20 Milligramm.
Und man morgens 20 Milligramm.
Genau.
Abgesehen von Arterella Hipertoni, Bluthochturuk, was haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe rohe Kolosterinwerte.
Aber das wird auch behandelt von meinem Hausarzt.
Nehmen Sie irgendetwas dafür ein?
Ja, ich nehme 40 Milligramm abends ein.
40 Milligramm?
Was haben Sie?
Catovastatin.
Ja, müsst ihr sie nicht mehr weggehen?
Abends haben Sie gesagt?
Abends, richtig.
Seitdem haben Sie Hyperlipidemia, seit diesem Jahr?
Auch seit 10 Jahren.
Sind diese Beschwerden mit dieser Medikamenteuse-Teher für gut eingestellt?
Gibt es Probleme?
Ich denke nicht.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Mein Hausarzt macht einmal im Jahr eine Blutkontrolle.
Das wäre okay, hat er gesagt.
Ansonsten geht es mir jetzt auch.
Bluthoch messe ich selber nicht.
Ich glaube, der ist gut.
Ich habe nicht mehr gemessen.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nein, noch nie.
Haben Sie Allergien?
Hausstab.
Hausstab. Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, mit Niesen und mit Juckreize, mit einem Daumen.
Okay.
Gibt es gegen bestimmte Medikamente Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nicht das Schöße.
Okay, alles klar.
Sind Sie gegen Corona sowie Kinderkrankheiten geimpft?
Ich denke schon, ja.
Mein Hausarzt hat nichts dafür gesagt, wie ich es gesagt habe.
Alles klar.
Waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nee, letztes Jahr.
Mir ist eingefragt und auch eingefragt.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie oft nach der Toilette gehen müssen.
Ja, es öfters auch richtig.
Ich denke, dass das mit den Handwächsinfekten zu tun haben könnte.
Ich bin jetzt immer so zweimal in der Nacht, ich stehe auf.
Handwächsinfekte?
Ich habe gesagt, dass ich Handwächsinfekte habe, immer wieder seit 3 Monaten.
Ich glaube, dass ich damit zu tun haben könnte.
Zweimal in der Nacht stehe ich auf.
Okay.
Müssen Sie tagsüber normal zur Toilette gehen?
Ja, vielleicht ein oder zweimal mehr ungefähr.
Okay.
Ich habe kein Fieber nach.
Wollen Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ich habe noch etwas zu tun.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob es wichtige Vorerkrankungen in Ihrer Familie gibt.
Leben Ihrer Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch und mein Vater ist gestorben.
Meine Mutter hatte auch Blutdruck.
Sie hat eine Rhythmusstörung am Herzen.
Mein Vater ist einem Schlaganfall gestorben.
Vorher ist Ihr Vater gestorben?
Schlaganfall.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Geschwister.
Das ist ein wichtiger Problem bei Ihrer Familie?
Ich glaube, Sie haben jetzt Schilddosenprobleme, aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich habe nicht so viel Kontakt zu Ihnen.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Bürokaufmann.
Ich arbeite im Büro.
Was ist mit Ihrer Arbeit?
Wo gibt es keine Schilddosen?
Ich habe keine Schilddosen.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich bin geschildet.
Ihr seid geschildet?
Leben Sie alleine?
Ja.
Aber haben Sie Kinder nicht?
Ich habe einen Sohn.
Ein Sohn.
Ich lebe bei Ihrer Mama.
Ich bin für mich alle wichtige Fragen durch.
Wenn Sie etwas Hilfe geben möchten.
Kann das Krebs sein, was ich habe?
Ich mache dieser Gewichtsverlust sehr.
Das besorgt mich schon sehr.
Ja, ich wollte gerne wissen, ob Sie mir gesagt haben, dass Sie in letzter Zeit Gewichtsverlust haben.
Wie viele Kilogramm haben Sie?
Ich habe 8 Kilogramm.
In letzter Zeitung?
In sechs Monaten.
Obwohl ich gar nichts verändert habe.
Ihr repetiert, aber ist es normal?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Sie haben kein Nachschweiß beim Merk, oder?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Okay, das ist klar.
Wir sind fertig.
Wir können nicht ausschließen.
Wir haben erst mal einen
Ich werde jetzt mit meinem Obererst über Ihre Situation besprechen.
Dann habe ich wieder bei Ihnen sein.
Vielen Dank.
Danke.
Ich habe 11 Minuten.
Das ist gut, aber viele ...
Ich habe Exikler gewusst.
Nein.
Ich habe noch eine Frage von Kollegen.
Wie ist Ihr Durst?
Ja, ich trinke viel.
Welche Farbe hat Ihr drin?
Einfach gelb, wie immer.
Gelb.
Ist Ihre Irre vermindert oder vermindert?
Ich glaube etwas vermindert, weil ich das Wasser lasse.
Haben Sie einen Blende Wasser lassen?
Ja, hat ich gesagt, ich habe einen Brennband
auf und zu lassen.
3 Monate schon.
Haben Sie einen Juckkreis?
Juckkreis?
Ja.
Nein.
Dr. Riawus, Sie haben Ihre Fragen gestellt.
Sie haben gesagt, seit 3 Monaten,
Sie haben häufig Örininfekt oder Harninfekt.
Ja, weil es brennt.
Wie wurden Sie bis jetzt behandelt?
Ich habe mich selber geholfen.
Ich habe viel Blasentees getrunken, Wasser getrunken,
um das durchzuspülen und Schmerz und Dämonen zu nehmen.
Haben Sie schon einmal einen Beweis?
Eine Urinkultur oder Örnistik?
Nein.
Hier haben Sie eine wichtige Frage.
Sind Sie schon einer anderen Arzt gewesen?
Ich denke.
Ich war in den letzten 6 Monaten nicht bei einem anderen Arzt.
Ich habe mir nur die Medikamente von meinem Hausarzt für Blutdruck
und für den Kollastrin aufschreiben lassen.
Ich war nicht bei einem anderen Arzt.
Die letzte Arzkontrolle bei meinem Hausarzt war vor einem Jahr.
Sie haben immer ein Schwierigkeiten bei Wasser lassen?
Ein Handrank oder so?
Nein, das kommt eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich habe nur noch etwas zu brennen bei Wasser lassen.
Was haben Sie noch an einem Nase gefragt?
Nein, ich habe noch nichts.
Ich habe leider nichts gefragt.
Ich würde gerne wissen, ob Sie rauchen, Herr Zimmer.
Nein, ich haue nicht.
Sie haben auch Alkohol?
Nein, ich habe sie ab und zu.
Einmal im Monat oder zweimal im Monat mit Freunden.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Drogen ein?
Nein.
Schwindelig, wie euchselst sich?
Wenn ich mich belaste, wenn ich lange spazieren gehe
und wenn ich Sachen in meine Wohnung einkaufen,
wenn ich die Wohnung sauber mache,
dann, oder wenn ich lange Fahrrad fahre.
Wie ein Kursel oder Liftschwindel?
Nein, es ist so stummerig.
Ich muss kurz Pause machen.
Dann gehe ich wieder weiter,
und dann geht es wieder weiter.
Sie haben Drogen?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, dass ich es mache.
Ja, richtig.
Könnten Sie ein bisschen bescheiden?
Ich habe dann so eine Verschwamme gesehen.
Sie haben so eine Verschwamme gesehen.
Ich habe nicht genau genau das Gefühl, aber das ist eine Verschwamme.
Verschwamme, und dann geht es.
Herr Kollege, Sie haben eine Frage gemacht.
Und Sie haben keine Frage gemacht.
Könnten Sie ein bisschen bescheiden?
Nein.
Guten Tag Herr Oberhörs.
Ich habe heute einen Patienten bekommen.
Hätten Sie einen Zeit für mich?
Ja.
Er ist 55 Jahre alt.
Er ist 15, 19, 69 Geboren.
Er ist 90 Kilogramm schwer und 1,70 Meter groß.
Er hat sich bei uns wegen ein paar Monaten bestehend
fertig und gebiich verlust.
Nein, fertig.
Bitte, nein fertig.
Fertig, Könnten Sie bitte nicht sagen, kein fertig.
Dann, ich würde sagen, Leistungsverminderung.
Geht das?
Ja, ja.
Leistungsverminderung.
Oder verwendete Belastbarkeit geht auch.
Und gebiich verlust vorgestellt.
Darüber hinaus, sein in die folgende Begleitstörende
auch fällig.
Nocturis, Zweimal.
In einem Tag Poli-Röse-Störingen-Wertko unter Belastung.
Und er hat mir auch gesagt,
seit ein paar Monaten unter Rennen,
was er lassen, leider.
Und seit ein paar Monaten unter,
ich will noch mal sagen,
seit ein paar Monaten unter Han-Infektionen leider.
Han-Infektion.
Und jetzt, Herr Kollege, Begleitstörende.
Poli-Röse, Poli-Lack-Süree,
Biz-Röse, Wertko-Nicht-Röse.
Und Brennende-Wassalasen.
Ja, eine Röse, eine Auk-Röse.
Poli-Röse, Poli-Lack-Süree, Auk-Röse.
Und das ist das, was ich sagen will.
Das ist das wollte ich sagen.
Wenn wir fast alles geholfen haben.
Bisousverlust, bisousverlust.
Verschuhe meine Leistung bisousverlust.
Nicht Hm.
mirror Dee sowie Poli-Röse.
Einsei, Al has contrary in
20 mg, einmal morgens gut eingestellt ist und ein unterhyperlipidämis seit zehn Jahren,
die Atowastatin 40 mg, einmal abends eingenommen, ein genommenes Medikament gut eingestellt ist.
Er allergisch gegen Haustop, sie reagiert sich, Niesen und Priorities auf Haustop,
mit Niesen und Priorities, was bedeutet auf Medizin?
Polinot, Niesen, Niesen, was nicht.
Genitis gibt, Niesen, Sternuzio, was?
Sternuzio, Fachbegriff.
Lauf und Laufen der Nasen?
Er sei vollständig geimpft und Noxananamese war unauffällig auf ein, zweimal Alkohol zu bestimmter Anlass.
In der Familie Anamese fand sich bei der Mutta arteriale hypertoni und herzritmische Törung
bei dem Fatah miokatinfaktus der darangeştorgunist.
Nein, nein.
Bei Fatah, bei Fatah, der darangeştorgunist.
Nein, nein, nein.
Er ist ein Schlaghafen-Apoplektiv.
Er sei Brokofmann, geschieden und lebt alleine, habe ein Sohn.
Nach dem bisherigen Angaben gehe ich von einem Handwerksinfektion auf.
Aber der Feneren-Sialdiagnostisch kommt von einem Karsinom in Betracht.
Welche Karsinom?
Niermkarsinom, Panwexkarsinom, die könnte ich.
Sie gehen von einer Handwerksinfektion aus.
Richtig?
Richtig, ja.
Sie sagen, dass es auch ein Karsinom sein könnte wegen gewichtsverlust?
Ja, wegen gewichtsverlust.
Er hat ja keine richtige Besymptomatik.
Er hat keinen Fieber, er hat keinen Nachtschweiß und sein Gewichtsverlust ist jetzt 8 Kilo und 6 Monaten.
Okay.
Wie ist denn seine Ernährung? Haben Sie nach seiner Ernährung gefragt?
In der Praxis, die Appetitveränderung wurde verneint.
Fieber wurde verneint.
Wie ernährt sich der Patient?
Kocht er selber?
Ja, ich habe...
Was macht er?
Er hat danach nicht gefragt, aber wenn ich erst bei dem Patient bin, werde ich fragen.
Er ist ja geschieden, ne?
Ja, er ist geschieden.
Er kann ja kochen.
Das bedeutet, er ernährt sich von der Rosel.
Wissen wir nicht, müssen wir nachfragen?
Ja.
Was er ist?
Okay, also wir haben Gewichtsverlust, wir haben Müdigkeit, nicht belastbar.
Wir haben Polydebtsin, ein bisschen Polyuri.
Wir haben verschwommenes Sehen, also Wiesesverlust, Schwindel.
Er hat Handigsinfekt, also Dysnuriaktor, wie jeden Fall auch.
Woran müssen Sie noch denken?
Wir können auch Rheulitis, vielleicht denken.
Gibt es denn in der Familiengeschichte Vorerkrankungen von Vater oder Mutter?
Bei der Mutter befinden sich Arteriella, Hypertone und Herzrichtmusstörungen.
Und beim Vater?
Beim Vater ist Anapoxie gestorben, aber ich konnte die Krankheiten nicht mehr Notizen machen.
Ja, vielleicht hat er Diabetes gehabt, weiß ich nicht, müssen wir mal nachfragen.
Der Vater.
Okay.
Ich habe dir das gesagt, Sie haben es nicht gehört, wann sein.
Also ich würde auf jeden Fall bei ihm auch mal den Zucker kontrollieren.
Haben Sie gefragt, weil er zuletzt beim Haushalts gewesen ist?
Ja, er war schon beim Haushalts, aber es war unaufwendig, außer dieser Handinfektion.
Wann war er denn beim Haushalts gewesen?
Ja, in den letzten 6 Monaten, aber nicht in...
Vor einem Jahr.
Er war vor einem Jahr beim Haushalts gewesen, ja.
Vielleicht messen Sie nochmal den Zucker, wir müssen auch den Zucker kontrollieren.
Sie haben recht, es könnte eine Handinfektion sein, es könnte auch ein CA sein,
er könnte auch ein Routelkarzinum haben, aber er könnte auch einfach nur Zucker haben,
weil er Diabetes hat.
Ja, in Verlachnörden ist ein Differenzialdiok, also befindet sich auch Diabetes.
Ja, es kann Diagnose sein, ja.
Das müssen wir kontrollieren.
Was machen wir denn als diagnostische Verfahren dafür?
Natürlich, nahteköpferliche Untersuchung, Brutuntersuchung, Laboruntersuchung,
mit der Bechutung Brut-Suka, Infektionsverte, Infectionsverte, Unnirmverte...
Was messen Sie denn als Brut-Suka, wir hatten...
Ja, was messen wir, Brut-Suka, wir hatten...
Wir müssen erst mal OGTT in Nüchternen und Satt...
Wir haben eine Notaufnahme, da machen Sie kein OGTT, was machen Sie eine Notaufnahme,
was messen Sie für die Diagnose eines Diabetes-Militers?
Ja, ich gucke kleines Brutbild erst mal.
Ja, was noch?
Und ja, was noch?
Glucose, nehmen Sie ab mit Glucose?
Ja, was noch?
Ich hab nicht...
Anz, was meinst du?
Ja, genau, richtig, das müssen wir auch kontrollieren.
Das ist ganz wichtig, elementar dafür.
Er kann auch ein Zucker haben von 160, dann sagen Sie, okay,
das ist gar nicht so hoch, aber der HW1C ist bei 13 vielleicht.
Das kann sein.
Ja?
Ja, ja, es haben ja sich umargetlich Diabetes-Militers.
Müssen die nur einmal kontrollieren?
Ja, wir müssen erst mal kontrollieren, wir können ja vor der Untersuchung
leider nicht so viel sagen, aber diese Diagnose befindet sich
in meiner Differenzialdiagnose, so wie in Verdachtung.
Sehr gut.
Gut.
Therapie, Hocam?
Ja.
Ich habe Diabetes-Militers aufgemacht,
die Therapie untertagt sich in zwei Richtungen.
Wenn die Infektion von einem Weg auf die Hörte aufgemacht ist,
dann können wir vielleicht Flurokonin und Zymphthons
in der Medikamente verwendet werden.
Aber Diabetes-Militers aufgemacht,
können wir andere Medikamente im Betracht ziehen.
Was für ein Beispiel?
Ja, es gibt für Diabetes, ich gucke, es ist 50 Jahre alt,
deswegen haben wir unsere Verdachtdiagnose natürlich Diabetes-Types 2.
Deswegen, es gibt viele Medikamente,
dafür aber als erstes kommt natürlich Ernährung, Umstellung,
Lebensgewohnheit und Umstellung.
Aber danach vielleicht, wie können vielleicht,
zum Beispiel, Bighorn, Zylphthons, Urea, Glutason,
es gibt viele verschiedene Medikamente,
Therapien, Möglichkeiten in Tipps 2 Diabetes.
Was ist das bekannteste?
Metronik.
Metronik genau, zum Beispiel.
Enginierende Werte sind okay, hören Sie mit Metronik in Stad.
Natürlich, Sie haben mir gesagt, dass auch in nächster Zeit
dieser Patient viele Handwerksinfektionen ausgesst,
deswegen, die sollten im Urin Gullikose denken.
Ganz genau.
Ja, ganz genau.
Eigentlich im ganz einfacher Fall.
Ich habe immer Schmessbasiert gedacht.
Diabetes ist nicht immer gleich.
Jeder Mensch ist anders.
Es ist nicht immer, aber Sie haben vier Symptome gehabt,
die man Diabetes mindestens auftreten können.
Gewichtsverlust, Müdigkeit,
der Winter der Belastbarkeit,
dann verschäumertes Sehen, zum Beispiel.
Und was wir auch oft haben, nicht so oft,
aber kann vorkommen Handwerksinfektionen.
Das trifft nicht immer zu, aber kann vorkommen.
Und diese Polydipthin, also,
manche Menschen merken das gar nicht.
Sie sagen, ich trinke schon immer viel,
oder Sie sagen, ich habe viel getrunken,
weil ich diese Handwerksinfekte habe,
deswegen trinke ich viel.
Aber ich habe extra jetzt nicht diese Polydipthin
in den Vordergrund gebracht,
damit es ein bisschen schwieriger wird.
Ja.
Ich habe in Düsseldorf-Halle gibt es keine Diabetes-Meltis.
Das war mein Fehler.
Nein, nein, nein.
Aber ich meine, wie müß Sie wissen,
ich akzeptiere das natürlich.
Deswegen, ich habe erst mal Handwerksinfektionen gedacht.
In Düsseldorf-Halle gibt es keine Diabetes-Meltis,
aber gibt es eine Pankratitis und deswegen
häufige Fragen bei der Diabetes-Meltis.
Und erste Frage,
bei der zum Beispiel Patientin,
der SUKA,
35, was machen Sie?
Ein Insulterapin.
Was stellen Sie?
Was stellen Sie ein?
Zum Beispiel, häufige Fragen in Düsseldorf.
Und Diabetes-Meltis, häufige Symptome,
hier, ich schreibe, deswegen gute Falle.
Ja, das war gut.
Nicht nur Düsseldorf, sondern auch alle Deutschland.
Ja, in meinem beruflichen Gang auch.
Das ist wichtig.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Haben Kollegen noch eine Frage?
Eine Frage.
Warum sollen wir nicht vertickt sagen, als Müdigkeit?
Im Mittwoch hat unser Onkulurgie Sametin gesagt,
dass die Faktik eine große Fachbegriffe,
nur bei der Krebserkrankung,
diese Fachbegriffe sagen können,
diese Symptome, Müdigkeit,
Schwehe Symptome, nicht fatik, deswegen.
Abgeschlagenheit oder Müdigkeit oder Abgeschlagenheit?
Abgeschlagenheit, Erschöpfung, Leistungsverlust, Müdigkeit,
und so weiter, aber nicht fatik.
Abgeschlagenheit steht für fatik in diesem Protokoll,
deswegen, aber ich verstehe, was Sie meinen.
Aber wie sollen wir darauf beachten?
Ich gebe so, aber in diesem Falle steht fatik für Abgeschlagenheit.
Deswegen habe ich so geschrieben, aber das wird auf jeden Fall ich in meinem Kopf halten.
Abgeschlagenheit ist stärker als Müdigkeit.
Fatik ist stärker als Abgeschlagenheit.
Vielleicht gibt es eine...
Herr Kollege, was Sie sagen?
Fatik wird hauptsächlich tatsächlich so in der
Krebsmedizin, Palliativmedizin benutzt.
Man benutzt es nicht im täglichen Alltag, man sagt eher Müdigkeit
und weniger oder reduzierte Belastbarkeit,
aber fatik ist, wenn man so wirklich langfristig chronische Müdigkeit hat.
Ich benutze das im täglichen Gebrauch nicht, also sehr selten.
Ich habe noch Fragen?